welcome to lodo welcome specifically to
coorsfield at 20th and blake streets the
rockies welcome in the oakland a's they
matched up with oakland earlier this
year took two straight from them on the
west coast oakland's had a great season
they're 30 and 18. they're in first in
the als by six and a half games and the
rockies
know they need to get hot
but you gotta start it with one game at
a time maybe antonio sensatella on the
hill he pitched against oakland earlier
this year and was successful two runs
over five innings in his first
appearance of the year and now senza can
get out of it if he can get the veteran
canna one ball and two strikes
and that's a fair ball diaz great throw
fuente takes the catch
wonderful job by sensatella after giving
up hits to the first two he faced
he gets out of it without relinquishing
a run they'll be taking on them
annihilator sean manaya
making his tim team leading 10th start
of the season he's been throwing the
ball really well
4-0 with a 198 era
over his last five starts rimel tapia
will start the night off
swing gonna miss ball down and away and
that's out number one here in the bottom
of the first here's tony kemp kemp at
273 he's got three rbis
he lifts one in the air pretty deep left
center field pallar on the move and
pilar makes the catch lam will tag hill
trot in to score so tony kemp does the
job gets a sacrifice fly to give the a's
a one nothing lead so here's the piston
nolan who's batting 261
and no two pitch ironado swings and
misses well that's not something you see
every day is aronado chase a couple
pitches out of the zone here's kevin
pollard
good pitch right on the inside corner
pilar didn't like it
but i'm not sure
he's got a whole lot to argue about that
looks like a
pretty darn good pitch
matt kemp
and another strikeout for sean monae he
strikes out the side
and we got a one-nothing a's lead
heading to the third and they're loaded
up
for charlie blackman
this could be a huge out and it is well
you get charlie blackman who just kills
left-handed pitching
but mania makes the big pitch there and
the rockies leave him loaded
lamb walked starting the second inning
and then would eventually score on the
sacrifice fly
smoke to right blackman turning around
he's going to play it off the wall picks
it clean fires it back in lamb hustling
for second and he is safe the ball came
nicely right back to blackman who fired
it in but lamb runs pretty well
just beat the tag it's nolan aronado to
see what he can do against mania
and aaron
strikes out
robbie grossman
and he hits this on the right side easy
play for hampson and senzatella does a
great job lead off doubled by kemp
and he does not score so it remains one
nothing
josh fuentes leads off
2-2 this is deep in the hole simeon sets
his feet low throw fuentes beat it and
the ball goes up the line a little bit
josh to second and now he's gonna turn
it up and try to go to third throw by
olsen not gonna get him
great base running by josh fuentes
so now the rockies great opportunity to
tie it this ball crush deep left field
get up get out go
two run home run
and the rockies take the lead first rbi
obviously first home run for diaz
for colorado jp
a strikeout and pop to first
and that's going to be a base hit so the
rockies have the first two on here in
the sixth
trying to add on
so here's the right man
josh fuentes
and this will get it done deep left
field it's going to stay in the ballpark
grossman
on the edge of the track
and tagging from first is kemp and matt
is in there good base running from kemp
rocky's leading three to one how about
that josh fuentes the cousins getting it
done as soon as he hit it it took a
couple steps out of the box he started
clapping his hands because he knew he
got the job done
jonah heim
and this could be a double play ball oh
wow
how good was that in the same motion he
fielded it he flips to story
and it turns into a real easy four six
three bring up marcus simeon
line drive get up handy two outs but
among second baseman with at least 10 or
more games at second base
he's second
in range factor
[Applause]
this is to hampson backhand
and how about that
you all better hit it somewhere else
what a night for garrett hampson with
the glove what a night for antonio senza
senza trying to
produce a complete game now jake lamb
two balls two strikes on the ground flet
diesel glove it to santa that is a
complete game three to one victory for
the rockies
what a performance by antonio sensatella